sickle cell anemia is an inherited blood
disease that affects your red blood
cells in this disease an abnormal
protein molecule called hemoglobin s
changes your disc shaped flexible red
blood cells into rigid sickle-shaped
cells
Sickle cells can block blood flow and
can cause pain and tissue damage and
Sickle cells don't last as long as
normal red blood cells
as a result your blood has less red
blood cells than normal
this condition is called anemia
treatment options for sickle cell anemia
may include medicines or procedures to
help relieve symptoms or in certain
cases a hematopoietic stem cell
transplant to potentially cure the
disease
antibiotics and vaccine shots for
diseases can help prevent infections
your health care provider May advise you
to take pain relievers for severe or
chronic pain one of the most common
medicines for long-term treatment of
sickle cell anemia is called hydroxyurea
it helps reduce pain by preventing
damage to your red blood cells it also
reduces the risk of long-term
complications
other prescribed medicines that help
prevent complications and improve
long-term outcomes include prison
lizumab voxelitor and L-glutamine if you
have an episode of very severe pain you
may have a procedure called a blood
transfusion this replaces the Sickle
cells with healthy red blood cells
for young patients who have or are at
risk for complications from sickle cell
anemia a hematopoetic stem cell
transplant may be advised it can cure
some people who have this disease
before the transplant you may be given
chemotherapy drugs radiation therapy or
both this will destroy the abnormal
blood-forming stem cells in your bone
marrow
then you will receive healthy stem cells
from either the bone marrow or blood of
a donor the donor is often a family
member whose tissue type closely matches
yours
the healthy blood-forming stem cells
from the donor will travel through your
blood to your bone marrow where they
will make normal red blood cells instead
of Sickle cells
to find out more about treatments for
sickle cell anemia talk to your health
care provider